when I was 22 and I worked at and I I
had I obviously just left Jersey Mike's
I started working at Spade I started
making a little bit more money I have a
buddy of mine his name is mad Moody mad
Moody is like a 65 ginormous dude from
Watts California he's a rapper I met him
he used to be a security guard at a
dispensary and when I worked at Jersey
miks we would do switch of roots okay
and he would come bring us a bag of some
goodies and we would give him two free
sandwiches and he would walk out the
door and he became a really good friend
to all of us over the years who kept in
touch
um and so moody and I have always kind
of stayed in touch and I remember I was
like yo I'm looking I'm looking for some
things I'm looking for some some weed
but like good weed kind of kind of like
under the table it's going to be cheaper
than what we would buy it in stores it's
something in La called secret sesh and
secret sesh is like invite only like
they don't put the invites out so people
can see him it's only word of mouth and
when you go it's in this tiny room dude
I drove down
I was in the Lexus MH in Downtown LA a
block from skid row at 11:30 at night
that's that's not the place to be me uh
and two buddies of mine whose names I
will not give um I don't know for what
reason I just don't think I talk to one
of them anymore but we go up there we
walk into this building at the front of
this abandoned 12 story office building
are two armed guards out front not sh s
armed security guards both with
bulletproof vests helmets and both have
an AR a secondary on the back and a
pistol on the side I'm like like yo
where the [__] am I it's cash only so
like I have like $400 of cash in my
pocket I have a little Satchel with me
like I'm expecting to go pick up a good
amount of weed so I can pack it and
leave it's cash only really
easy and I they're like all right go up
eight flights of stairs no oh no
elevator no elevator dude the B the
building was abandoned every floor I
went up there was locks and bars on the
doors except for one on the eighth floor
so you get up to the eighth floor you
walk in and it is just this you walk in
lights are all off there's a DJ going
and it's like a mini cannabis convention
and there's just booths of people in
this room that's probably no bigger than
my living room at my house right now
yeah and it is just like just packs and
packs of people there's like people from
legit dispensaries there people who just
have like like uh like under the oh like
back door [__] I walked up this table
this dude had just like you know the
brand cookies right yeah just bags and
bags of cookies and I was like how much
for the ounce and he was like 100 bucks
and I was like is it real and he was
like yeah and there was a bar Cod and
everything that you could scan for
authenticity all of it was real $100
ounce that would be 400 in stores yeah
so it was just tables and tabl of this
and so and then there's people giving
out free dabs people smoking blunts like
everybody knows each other there's food
there's a taco sand like I was like this
is the [__] coolest place ever and
then we stayed for about an hour and a
half and then we all were like all right
cool I got my stuff said bye to Moody
grabbed my boys and we walked
out the minute we got onto that street
the armed guards were no longer outside
they were inside the door so they went
to open the door to let you out and then
closed it back and it was just you on
the street I felt a little safer with
the armed guards out there when I walked
in didn't feel safe anymore the fact
that the armed guards went inside it was
it just you no it was me and my me and
my buddies cuz I drove us so I was like
you guys aren't getting home without me
so no splitting up this is Buddy system
I will be holding hands if I [__]
have we're not and I parked no joke like
two blocks down two blocks away because
I'm not trying to park out front of a
building where I'm going in to pick up a
bunch of drugs illegally yeah in cash
you know what I'm saying like there's
just a lot of you bet you wish you had
parked right in front oh yeah cuz by the
time we start walking like you know in
Downtown LA bro it's like oh dude and
you were High super super high like I
wasn't uncomfortably high but I was
uncomfortable where I was yeah being
high like to a point to where I'm in my
pockets and I have I'm starting to put
my my keys in between my Knuckles and
I'm just starting to be ready and
prepared for like whatever the [__] may
go down I have everything in that
backpack and this little string bag and
I have that string bag in my hoodie
pocket so right now I'm just walking
hands in my pockets on top of my stuff
nothing in my pockets that no one could
take or swipe and my I'm ready with my
keys and I look around to my friends and
I'm like we all good and they're like oh
I'm prepared and I look in and one of my
buddies has a a a switchblade in his
pocket with he's ready and the other
dude already has his keys and his
knuckles also and I'm like I'm like are
we ready to throw down right [__] now
like but you know in Downtown LA man the
more corners you turn the more people
just show up out of the darkness yeah
dude it's The Walking Dead like dudes
are walking by people on Bic
I saw the same dude on the same bicyle
three times he cired us and came back on
different blocks by the time we got to
my
car I like for me dude the three bicycle
that's not a good sign no same dude on
the bicycle who I'd seen three times I
was like I was like oh bro we got we got
to pick up the pace they're like they go
no if we walk fast people will get
suspicious I go if we don't walk fast
there's a dude on a bike he we're not
going to be faster than that like I was
like I'll hit him in the car and we'll
deal with the repercussions later I was
like but I am not you're not hitting him
with my car would you rather me hit him
with the car me dead yeah yeah Bingo
that's what I thought I was like we
we'll deal with the repercussions later
if it even comes to that yeah and also
by the way I was like I know my dad will
be okay if I hit a dude on the bike
who's trying to rob us or do something
to us if I hit him with a car my dad's
gonna be like yeah okay let's just go
get it fixed did you kill him no all
right we're good like that's that's what
it's GNA be we got in a I got in a car
accident in high school and I ran into a
tree and my dad was in California the
time and my brother called and said Josh
has been in a car accident and the first
question he asked was which car was he
tring yeah of course he
did he was like yeah yeah cool but was
he in my
car that's hilarious but yeah so that
that's the only time I could think of
like I was in an uncomfortable position
but I we ended up getting to the car I
did that thing cuz your car I could keep
the key in my pocket and unlock the door
I did that and got in and realized the
dudes were in the car and I was like oh
[__] that only unlocks my door and I
start like spamming the unlock button
they get in the car and I I'm how psych
you guys skirted off out of there well I
skirted off out of there with all with
all the things I had purchased with the
extra money I still had and with my
[__] life so like and after that I
remember Moody texting me two weeks
later he's like yo another uh another
secret session and I was like cool
where's it at he goes same spot and I
was like no I'm good won't be there I
was like I will catch you next time
brother yeah I will not we going back to
whatever that is unless those armed
guards follow me to my car like I need I
need a personal escort back to my Lexus
please like a like a privileged white
boy